joining me now is the actors I want to
make her a very popular situation comedy
my family is coming back for a run on
your television screens thank you very
much indeed and I assume as they want to
make her that because of co-ed and all
that this is not new episodes no no I
think I think they're the very first
ones the ones I've seen the very first
ones that we did and I've never seen it
before because I don't like watching
myself at all but so it's quite good
surprised are you going to make an
exception in lockdown and watch yourself
yeah because it's it's fascinating I
mean 20 years ago so it's a fact that
it's still funny is this great because
it's also very good casting all the
actors that are in it very beautifully
put together with very beautifully put
together and I think we had a lot of
good and how has it affected your plans
your professional plans what have you
had to counsel well I was just starting
to film Britannia Britannia three sky
and that was two weeks in and then we
had to stop so I don't know how we're
gonna be able to sustain not working
which is a shame and it's but what the
great thing is that you watching nature
just gently explode is has been the joy
and so we're very lucky to be in the
middle of nowhere so it's been great in
that way and I do everything that I do
when I'm not what I'm supposed to be
learning my lines so it's been great I
mean we do know that obviously did the
entertainment industry is one of those
has been hit incredibly hard by by
lockdown because basically you can't get
to audiences or get to work to perform
do you think there is a need for special
assistance from the government of course
of course it's a this happens in Europe
in Germany and in France there is the
arts are considered
something very valuable which our
country seems to ignore that this is a
vital part of life and to have it
together nice even rock concerts or
concerts themselves art galleries the
South Bank Centre for instance of that
is massively fruitful and also the fact
that we the arts bring in how many
billions of pounds into into this
country so it's it's also the sharing is
sharing of an experience which you don't
really get when we're talking like this
it's it's a specialized thing and the
you can feel and in the theater for
instance you can feel as an actor you
can feel when an audience is bored or
happy or responding and and that sort of
energy you don't get from this kind of
and what and what are the prospects now
we had a alarm announcement for The
Globe Theatre which course was founded
by your father
is that going to survive oh it's going
to be it's going to have to be I mean I
don't know what he would have done
something but it's it's it says it was a
very special place it's a special piece
of architecture is a special piece of
British English language and without it
I think now now that it's there after 27
years it's got to stay it has to stay
but then the arts have to stay because
it's vital for for us to use this
English language that we have which is
so rich and diverse